por una parte alemania que viene a
buscar una vez más levantar la corona
alemán y ha ganado en ocho de las doce
ediciones de la eurocopa por ocho por
ahora ha venido haciendo un excelente
partido y una excelente campaña a lo
largo de todo este torneo marcando 11
goles y sobre todo es la única selección
que por ahora no ha encajado goles está
en cero esa portería alemana como les
decía viene haciendo digamos un poco un
papel de bajo perfil pero siempre muy
eficaz con una excelente defensa de las
alemanas como lo muestra el hecho de que
no hayan encajado goles por ahora pero
por supuesto tenemos preguntas acerca de
qué va a pasar en el ataque el día de
hoy en vista de que alexandra popp y
svenja huth se quedan solas en vista de
que clara brull pues dio positivo por
kobe 19 así que vamos a ver martín a
mountain que el burgo como mueve sus
fichas hoy con ese equipo y por el otro
lado pues está francia dirigida por el
coi india francia que llega que está
haciendo historia es lo que ha venido
diciendo también su directora técnica al
llegar a esta semifinal y antes de
pensar en esa final pues tienen que
vencer a las alemanas francia tiene una
muy buena defensa con su capitana o en
diagonal que es la torre finalmente de
esa defensa hay que decir también que en
el medio también tiene muy buenos
jugadores entre ellas hay oro que
seguramente hará un excelente duelo
frente a la alemana macul y también
suelto de brits y en la punta pues a
francia tiene excelentes jugadoras sobre
todo del fincas camino quien es un
excelente partido en a cuartos de final
ante holanda una jugadora con mucha
presencia con mucha energía y francia
que pues finalmente en ese último
partido que disputó pues se disparó 33
veces a portería y solamente marcaron un
gol que fue ese penalti cobrado por
pericet así que hay muchísimas cosas en
juego entre estos dos equipos como sea
va a haber digamos historia por un lado
historia por el otro pero sobre todo lo
interesante de este partido es que
francia por primera vez puede digamos
verde o ir a jugar frente a alemánia
digamos de 'tú a tú' así que de pronto
un duelo un poquito más balanceado más
equilibrado así que veremos cómo pasan
las cosas esta noche aquí en milton
keynes